it's only an hour into a relaunch at
Mike at Nell's we're going to be firing
hold hold on I have four filets up here
Mike has slipped back into his old ways
and is refusing to share the leadership
of the kitchen with Dan you're going
ahead I have no idea what you're talking
about dude and a successful relaunch is
in Jeopardy I need you running this and
coordinate the kitchen properly and I
want you to be behind him yes yes sir
all right let's pick up one strip medium
picking up ribeye shrimp chicken and
ribeye I'm I'm I'm losing you confirming
to me you're not listening one little
bit I know it's hard but it's not
[__] difficult it will be if you
don't listen get them working for you
but I need Daniel now to start firing
these orders right I got you come on you
can do this this restaurant is not all
about me I need help to run it and Dan a
man to do it order in strip filet medium
riy medium excellent let's go next up
two skirt one rare one mid rare I got it
Daniel rare's going on it'll be 2
minutes with Dan regaining control of
the tickets yeah tell me again what's
going out right now fet medium Cod fet
medium and a Cod got it the kitchen has
found a proper Rhythm medum well on the
right chef Mike yes sir your steaks look
fantastic I got it baby my table loves
all their steaks thank you I got zero
complaints about the food tonight
everything was amazing steak rested yes
they are put it out baby Dan was really
into his job tonight and really took a
lot of pressure off of
me like the way it looks in here the
food will be out in plenty of time and
you'll love it it was very rewarding
walking around out there I felt my
father's Spirit here watching over me
and everybody and it felt wonderful how
you doing Daddy I can't get the smile
off my face my dad completely turned it
around it's great to see him so happy
Mike how was the dining room I'm good
everybody looks happy and smiling keep
me that way all right brother board is
clear Chef Ramsey showed my staff that
they need to support what I do everybody
did great I think this is going to be
most successful place around
[Music]
here let me tell you something when I
first arrived your head was in the grill
stubborn wouldn't come out you've
transformed and work with me thank you
in there right now is the spirit of
Nelly I agree and for me that is enough
to confirm that you can do it I believe
in you thank you
sir thank you so much for everything we
appreciate everything you did and more
thank you it's been a pleasure and hon
good to see Bud y keep it going yes well
done Chef Ram inspired me I was ready to
close this place up but we got through
it we persevered and now I'm going to
rock this place I'm going to rock this
town come here my father Nelson would be
crying right now overwhelmed by Joy I
know he's watching Paddy thank you I
hope you're proud of
him oh come on we're not getting
anywhere guys we've already sent the
appetizers just check out was that six
no somebody to got to three okay then
check six then check six it's not the
same table no just checking if it's the
same
order
sorry we're sending food out twice
they're eating too table a for [__]
sake come on Michael table six and three
are eating do you know what you're
doing
Mike scre up boy Michael need to step up
to the plate I know it everyone knows
except fry needs to K Michael in the ass
M I need you to step up stop panicking
you're right there's something difficult
here I know bring the team together we
got this we're going to Pro you got it
word this line have the balls to do it
mistakes are going to happen it all
depends on how you handle the mistake
John table 10 did they get older
appetizers yes they did Alex did you
bring this to 19 right an olives and a
callary Table 19 I got to keep keep it
together get my head on straight have
confidence in myself and stick to the
game plan right now listen I need one
partelli one Cod one rete day and then
we'll worry about everything else but
that I need now yes sir come on keep it
going you got to drive the team I got
you got yes how we doing on 18 I comment
right now got to talk to each other guys
okay I want to sit in the window
together good right here right here
thank you sir table six with Chef
Ramsey's encouragement Michael has
rallied back okay lasagna lasagna
lasagna one lasagna in the window baby
beautiful baby food is flowing into the
dining room again at a steady Pace
yay oh this is so good you're going to
love it no snacks it tastes great and no
complaints what did you like about the
pizza the whole P DNA how is everybody
out there they're loving it everybody's
loving it they're loving it yeah gotcha
you gave me a chicken parm with no home
is a shrimp coming with it it's
incredible having Michael finally step
up he's doing a good job he actually
sounds like a boss today that's the
first you guys are doing a great job the
food looks AB absolutely gorgeous thank
you thank you Michael is now working
together with us hey guys come on baby
one more and the finish line is here
they're supposed to be like that we
looking for that for a long time let
everything go okay oh my God excellent
back on the
[Music]
M okay how you feeling good yes yes
feedback they love the food the old
customers right Mama Rose I thought you
going to bed huh you happy
yeah I'm very happy look after your son
I will let him spoil you now that's I
need you you need to sit and relax and
go around the corner of a little game of
bingo he's good enough to take over yes
he is I wasn't proud to see my go be the
boys and hopefully things work out and
be bettered uh I'd like a little word
with you yes
sir
okay three important words that right
now I need you to remember stay the
course if you don't do that we're coming
off track and we're going to slip back
day by day to our old ways stay the
course stay the course I can't hear you
stay the course take a big deep breath
and Shout at me Chef in my restaurant
I'm going to stay the course
good well done thank you sir good night
thank you this was just a phenomenal
experience and the thing that CH me the
most Chef Ramsey that's a God's honest
truth stay the course you got it brother
good night good night he believed in me
and he said I can do it I truly believe
I can do it good job Michael you proud
of me yeah thank you very much do laugh
now no more okay I'll try I'm
tired you're in good hands yeah thank
you I love I love you
too where's uh shell in the
office
[Music]
shell can I uh can I talk to you
please Shell Shell there's no point
making yourself look any more stupid
shell just 2
seconds not going to
argue she's not coming we don't need her
come
on Shelly needs to listen to Chef Ramsey
you just can't close ears to someone
that's come to help you please I really
don't have anything to say you don't
need to have anything to say just go
outside out of respect for your staff I
love my staff well then you want them to
walk out on you and you have the
restaurant man I'll clean up tonight my
forget about cleaning up tonight what
about the rest of the days de and I'm so
ashamed of you that I don't know what to
do Shelly we have worked our ass off God
can you please you are if you are done
close the dam place down let's go
tyone I don't believe Shel deserves all
this great help she got I mean someone
like me that's been cooking and went to
culinary school would kill for something
like this opportunity you know it
saddens me so
[Music]
much okay I know it's been a rough
night but on a personal note I just want
to say thank you why because you guys
work your butt off nobody gave
up there's something personal about soul
food for me I started a small little
documentary called Kitchen Nightmares 7
years ago and my first ever restaurant
was a Soul Food shack it's why I started
to put him back into the industry and
you guys deserve success he did a
fantastic job Chef Ramsey he's up there
with the best Angels I'm just so
delighted and so grateful and we are
going to do do our part to make him
proud of us we definitely will make sure
that your efforts were not in vain thank
you thank you thank you
you Shelly had the world's greatest Chef
in here to teach her and to help her
business but she may throw this all the
whole system out the window with the
whole menu only time can tell can we
have 30 seconds please I think this is
my office are you asking me for 30
seconds at my office yes I am absolutely
not okay that just sums it up yeah
that's the only thing I haven't
changed I really wanted a happy ending
tonight why because this week I've met
some amazing people mother Mary what a
sweetheart and a phenomenal cook ma team
that guy has a bright future and he is
packed with passion but the fate and the
the future of blackberries rest in the
hands of shell and unfortunately
restaurants do not succeed when they're
run by a
dictator I planted a mouse and she
crazy in the weeks that followed nice to
see you customers responded well to the
changes Chef Ramsey made to the menu and
the decor steak is tender after
witnessing the positive
reviews surprisingly Shelly embraced all
that Chef Ramsey has done for
blackberries nice right beautiful I like
it I was so skeptical but Chef Ramsey
has opened up a new world for us here at
blackberries I'm ready for change it was
difficult for me to see that at the
beginning but here it is the truth is
the light you guys
enjoy it's relaunch night and the
president of the Brooklyn burrow has
arrived welcome
toito and the timing couldn't be worse
Eduardo is a mess and Chef Ramsey knows
he has to step in turn those States over
2 seconds with Me 2 seconds literally 2
seconds come on what's the matter huh
what's the matter I'm [__] all over I
know you're [__] all over the place
but what you're not doing for you for me
for the resturant no one's
talking okay I'm going to put my
thiswatch into pre because I need do
something I okay come on Eddie I got you
I got you [__] me talk just do something
all come
on okay you can do it come come here
come here the president of the board is
here and the kitchen is a ner right now
I have to do something and I have to do
it now here we go here we go let's go
let's expedite this we're concentrating
maras okay nice here we go that's the
most important order of the night as one
guy we cannot afford to piss off tonight
exactly
Roo the new the new and the Roo fish
fish coming out right now excellent Ro I
need
another beautiful beautiful guys we need
more plantings can we do we have more
it's coming and five give me five give
me five thank
you thank
you bud Kata and me are working together
well again I going to do this and you do
that let's go with Kata and Marcelo
finally working together as a team all
right the kitchen is back on track this
is B3
B3 and now the only thing left to make
the night of success is satisfying the
burough president how was everything
here they loved everything yeah baby
yeah Fu Marcel to control the whole
situation he was very put together very
calm very relaxed he really got things
going and that make me gain more respect
for him well it means a lot for us for
you guys to be here I appreciate it
thank you nice to see you best thank you
that's it that's it I think that the
passion is back I'm back I'm back again
thank you thank you so much byebye have
a good
night Kata and Marcelo came together
like the team they once were and
Mojito's relaunch was a success right
tonight wasn't perfect but I did see one
thing that that I haven't witnessed at
Mojitos for the first time and that was
teamwork well done what do you think
about the future of this restaurant now
before it was really uncertain we didn't
know if we were going to last a month a
week a day now we have a long-term
future it's up to both of you are you
seriously willing to put your past aside
and commit to your baby I already a
start I feel great this night I get the
energy that I had 5 years
ago it feels great to see Marcelo smile
him showing his emotions just s ring my
heart do me a
favor tell each other how important it
is you are my partner and I need your
support and I need your commitment so if
you committed to me I'll be 110 1202 200
committed to you to make it work and to
the restaurant I I need
you to
continue you are the the half of that
I'm going to do everything that it takes
to make it work you guys work well
together tonight proved that I feel in
in in my heart that I get cata back I
get my partner back don't stop You' be
mad too come out
[Music]
my thank you good to see you guys great
team loser I'm telling you one last time
you're a [__] [__] while
Sebastian lets off steam
outside in inside the kitchen has come
to a
halt Gordon has put an enormous amount
of effort into Sebastian's he has also
been impressed by the staff's
willingness to change they look lovely
don't they huh are they going out
now wow it's hard to
hear that what you've done is a
failure come on guys salmon and chicken
away yeah roasted vegetables let's go
it's uh it's true some of the stuff he
says maybe I was a little twisted with
my ideas and my goals if you look at the
numbers then I guess it looks like I'm
feeling okay ready happy little size of
lemon knife please it's a slap of
reality and I know he's
right it's not easy to
accept but I guess before you grow you
got to accept it keep them in there get
them nice and
yeah it's my family my my kid
makes you want to work harder let's go
what's next can you talk to me big boy
shmp yeah good I don't have the degree I
didn't go to school I know I've Got
Talent I'm a damn good cook I'm not
giving up I'll get there I'll get
[Music]
there there was just kind of looking
around and we didn't know what was going
to
[Music]
happen I was speechless I couldn't even
tell you how worried I was cuz um he's
supposed to be this big bad guy right I
could feel him watching me I felt like
he would said what are you going to do
about your kitchen it's falling apart
I'm like you're right I got I got I got
to fix this how we
looking are we we back on top now oh yes
where are yeah top yeah not confused
[Applause]
good Sebastian just came in and he was
ready to go give me a large crustini I
got you AB perfect perfect perfect once
things started going smoothly Sebastian
seem to be a lot more optimistic get a
little excited in here I appreciate the
enthusiasm the fact I've got one in a
million opportunity here I'd be a fool
not to accept it t send it out that's
good Salmon's on yes 11 let's go up up I
need us out on the fly9 with Sebastian
back in the saddle the staff rallies
together and turns the kitchen around
service has stepped up food is going out
on time and most importantly the
customers are
[Music]
happy bloody well done you took on the
changes well you all adapted change is a
challenge it's hard but I think it'll be
worth it in the long run it's everything
that we've worked for Lou Your
Enthusiasm is infectious you know that
coming from Chef Gordon made me feel
really good to know that that he saw
that in me so that was cool Andre happy
very yes yes yeah we started off slow
but hey we didn't crumble did we we got
more adjusted to the menu and things
started working a lot more smoothly for
us tomorrow it starts again yeah yes
well done yes up up
up very
good I respected the chef when he came
in my opinion changed of him when I met
him and he's reiterated to
me I don't have to agree with his
methods the result is what it
is